[Music]
every now and then
i get to meet someone who sees the world
completely
differently from the rest of us they
don't just have a new way
of doing things the way that things have
always been done but they do things
unlike anyone else matthew barzun is one
of those people
he saw the power of the internet pretty
early on
he also saw the power of small donations
in politics
pretty early on he was also the us
ambassador to sweden and great britain
and saw things that
others weren't seeing this is what i
love about matthew
he thinks differently this
is a bit of optimism
a few years ago in partnership with
penguin books
i started my own imprint called optimism
press
and unlike most imprints which are
usually
verticals they're based on a subject you
know they do cookbooks they do business
books
i wanted to publish the people and ideas
that i had met
on my travels that i believed
contributed to the greater good you know
i have this vision of a world that does
not yet exist
a world in which the vast majority of
people wake up every single morning
inspired
feel safe wherever they are and end the
day fulfilled by the work
that they do and i wanted to publish the
people and ideas that i believe took us
a little closer
to that ideal i published a book called
how to make plants love you which is
really a metaphor for how to treat
people
i published a book all about trust and
now
what i'm so excited is i get to publish
your book
the power of giving away power by
matthew barzin how does that sound
that's really good that's really good
because when you and i met i was just
astonished by how you
defer to others i watched it happen i
remember
the first time we ever met um when you
were
ambassador to the court of state james
and u.s ambassador to great britain
i i got to have a meeting with you and
your staff at the embassy
and i've had meetings with people uh
before who are in
positions of authority or positions of
power and they own the room
and you didn't you deferred to everyone
in the room
and i was blown away by that what is the
power of giving away power and
where did you learn that i've just sort
of been a witness to this
distinct kind of leadership in the
course of my
life thus far and watched
how people give away power
it's not sharing power because i think
sharing power sort of fundamentally
is about division it's like taking a
finite amount of it
and then dividing it up the leaders that
inspired me
they created power tell me a story that
helps me understand helps me see
what the power of giving away power
looks like it's 2006
and senator obama comes to visit my
adopted hometown of louisville kentucky
and we'd do a big rally and we didn't
know how many people would show up but 5
000 people showed up and there was a
spare
hour and i just figured he'd want to go
catch up on his blackberry with his
senatorial work but he said hey no were
there any republican or independent
friends you have from town who didn't
come to the rally and i said
sure he's like i'd love to just talk to
them so i call around we get a group
around the table
and senator obama doesn't say much he
really just sort of asks people about
their hopes and fears for the country
they go around and at the end everyone
said what an amazing
discussion what a great speaker he is
and i noted that he hadn't really
said much and one of the people who
couldn't make it to that meeting called
afterwards and said wow wow did he light
up the room
and so i found myself saying well yes
the room got lit up but not in the way
i think you might think he got everyone
else to light up and that's how the room
light up
i heard a statistic from jack daley the
famous sales coach
that a bad sales salesperson will ask
seven questions on average
per sales call whereas a good
salesperson will ask
32 questions per sales call and when you
give the other person the chance to talk
i mean i remember like a job interview
where i asked more questions than they
asked me and they thought it went
fantastic but they did all the talking
and it's really an amazing thing when
you give someone the power to speak to
to be
heard how grateful they are
to you i saw you give a little
presentation to some
junior folks at the embassy that i loved
where you make this point we know that
top-down
leadership doesn't work the command and
control you know do as i say i'm the
boss and we am the sort of already
a movement against that form of
leadership which we know
and the buzz word is bottom up and what
you so
eloquently pointed out is it's still a
triangle
is it still highly structured whether
you're going up the pyramid or down the
pyramid
same shape different direction and if
you really want to change the way
leadership looks and sounds to drive
innovation and trust
you throw the pyramid out entirely
because people freak out right
because they think if you throw the
structure of the pyramid out the only
alternative is chaos
well yeah and when we first met in
london david brooks whose columns i
i love talking about the world at the
time said it's like a hierarchy with its
head cut off
and then he said it's a swarm swarm is
such a
negative word and i thought yeah the
pyramid whether you're doing it top down
or bottom up
does have in its favor stability of some
kind
it's just not the only kind there's
another kind of order another kind of
stability
that a lot of these great leaders that
the book talks about have discovered
and it's pretty amazing i call it the
constellation
so you have pyramid thinking which is up
down in out that kind of way
constellation thinking in the
constellation mindset
says hey look we are each our own star
and we look at other people as other
stars and we can
choose to connect with them to make
useful patterns it is a mindset and it
is a way of
seeing thinking feeling and behaving
it is not like our default setting we
get very comfortable in the pyramid
or we say well i want to get rid of the
pyramid and i'll just be on my own but
that sort of leads to alienation so
there's this alternative out there for
us
if we can learn from these other leaders
can you share an example of what a
constellation looks like in practice
like you know how there's a you have a
dispute at the thanksgiving table or the
dinner table and someone settles it and
it's like well i'll google it right
but really what settles the argument
isn't google usually the first search
result you get
is wikipedia right wikipedia will settle
it for you so you're really wikipedia in
it and so the story of how
a commodities trader from alabama jimmy
wales
and his team developed what became the
largest human knowledge transfer
engine the world has ever seen is a
beautiful radiant constellation
they weren't saying well we are the
gatekeepers of knowledge and what should
be covered they opened it up to all of
us
and so you could write a sentence you
could write a paragraph you could
collaboratively
co-create and build an encyclopedia
article
and it will last forever where a lot of
organizations
get tripped up right it's like previous
to wikipedia we had the encyclopedia
the knowledge was owned edited by the
encyclopedia company britannica or
whoever
and when the internet showed up
microsoft introduced lincarda right
yeah which was basically just the
encyclopedia but online yeah it was a
digital pyramid but microsoft still
owned edited all the information and
what i find so fascinating about the
wikipedia example
is that wikipedia owns none of the
information
is not the editor is not the arbiter of
what goes in or goes out
but it's a crowd source thing and it has
some errors in it but so does the real
encyclopedia
[Laughter]
totally and what's interesting at the
time you mentioned
encarta i mean it was on its way to be
the richest company in the world
they could see the power of hyperlinking
they could see the power of
video compression they could see the
power of all sorts of things
there is one kind of power they couldn't
see which is the power in you and me
what i love is that clearly this
thinking has evolved from your own
experience and
your career has been remarkable you know
you were an entrepreneur and a business
leader
prior to you the way that political
donations were given was people would
give the max and politicians thought
you'd try and get the max from as many
people as possible and that's what
hillary clinton's campaign was doing
back in the day
and then you were one of the people who
said hold on
if we get 10 donations from a lot of
people that's more money than 2500
donations from a few people and which is
now the standard of political
fundraising today micro donations
and you were part of the group that
invented that
if my memory serves it came in partially
because
you're an introvert when you were told
to go fundraise totally
you were like i don't really want to go
talk to people and hit them up for money
but what i can do is throw a party i
think the idea of small donations wasn't
particularly
new normally what you do is you get 10
donations
late in the game by email mass email and
i was like you wouldn't wait
to field organize until the last minute
would you that'd be kind of
dumb you start early and i was like this
is a farming exercise like plant seeds
cultivate early if you wait till late
it becomes a hunting exercise and all
the language of fundraising which i
found
so abhorrent not only because i'm an
introvert but because
i am just have become allergic to
pyramid thinking like
target list snagging someone
hooking them i mean it's all hunting and
fishing metaphors and the math of
hunting
is if you aim and here i am in kentucky
so i'll use deer hunting which
may appeal to some and not to others but
others off so forgive me but
i mean if there's you know ten deer
standing under a tree and you're up in a
tree stand and you shoot at one
best case you get one nine run away
whereas if you're planting seeds which
is what we try to do with these low
dollar fundraisers once people have
invested
they're probably going to want to invest
again they're going to want others to
invest and you get that kind of good
math
constellation map i love this and i want
to underscore this because
i think it's such a great point because
i think so much of what we do
looks a lot more like hunting like in
business than it does
like farming some of the reasons are
because we have pressures to do things
on certain days by certain times
it's you know go out and get this bring
me back the results
as opposed to farming which is a little
more like i'm not 100
sure when we will get our crop i know
it's approximately
in this time frame the harvest but i
don't know the day
where a hunt i can go out today and i
can i can
bag me something and that's it so
fundamentally this
is about how we manage uncertainty
yeah and the pyramid mindset tries to
factor it out
and so it picks a set goal and it works
its way backwards and i actually think
that's a backwards way of working
the constellation way i'm sure look it
has goals and things that we'd like to
achieve
but it is open-ended and it just sort of
embraces uncertainty at the core
and this is fundamentally infinite
thinking totally and it's amazing how
many organizations
attempt to be hunters and they're so
happy when they bag that one deer
then when it's eaten it's eaten it's
over and you have to go out and hunt
again
where farming is a process rather than
an event farming is an ongoing thing
that you just
you and that's how business should be
that's how politics should be i love
thinking of these things as
process rather than events and dr karst
talked about it he liked to think of it
as play
you know business should be about the
playing not about the winning
because there is no winning the fun
little parlor trick to play
i encourage listeners to try this
sometimes so let's say you're talking to
10 people and you say
what's the opposite of winning this is
just to warm them up and they all say
losing and you're like yeah i agree
and i said now what is the opposite of
winning and losing
from my deeply imprecise and
unscientific method of having asked
you know a thousand people this question
nine out of ten of us
will basically say i don't know not
playing
sitting it out one in ten will say
to your point earlier playing loving
laughing learning
all the verbs that we actually
value in life but it's so quick that
if we present it that way which is the
pyramid way
not winning and losing is nothing and
it's like it's everything
it's everything and we know it this is
supposed to be a bit of optimism you
know that's so depressing no i think
it's depressing
that nine out of ten people when
challenged with the question
what's the opposite of winning and
losing the answer is not playing sitting
out of the game
being a spectator whereas the reality of
not winning or losing as you said it's
the joy of play it's the laughing it's
it's lego versus baseball
totally the reason i find it optimistic
and not depressing
is that if you look at the facial
expressions of the nine out of ten of us
who say not playing
once someone says playing their
shoulders drop a little bit
and they're like oh right like you know
you don't
win a marriage you could lose one so it
starts an interesting conversation
the reason bottom up feels good for a
second it's really no better than top
down
but it's fatal flaw is you are either
thinking of yourself as at the bottom or
worse you're thinking of other people is
at the bottom
and once you have that vision of
yourself and others
it's a doom if you think of yourself as
a star and you think of other people's
stars and be like oh what could we do
together that is
open-ended optimistic let's say that
again the weakness of the pyramid is
that as appealing as the bottom
sounds either you see yourself at the
bottom or you see somebody else at the
bottom
so one is self-deprecating the other one
is judgmental
and in your model of the constellation
if i see myself as a star
confidence and i see other people as a
star i see
value in other people yeah you see value
in them you see power potential in them
and the opportunity is not lift up push
down the opportunity is partnership and
draw lines which is what the
constellations are right they're
patterns of dots totally which by the
way
are not self-evident right this is why
it's not depressing to me like
orion's belt isn't obvious
like you have to be shown and be like do
you see how those
things make a line but there is no line
it's a visual leap
to choose to see it and so once you
choose to see it like these
constellation leaders did
then we can all learn we're all capable
of seeing thinking feeling and acting
this way so you turned me into an
optimist again what i thought was
depressing was that nine out of ten
people
saw not playing as the only alternative
when you can't win or lose
and what what is optimistic about is it
only took one person to say
no joy the play that
nine people went oh yeah and so yeah the
depressing part is we're all thinking
about pyramids and top down and bottom
up
and all it takes is one person to say
have you seen this constellation
and everyone goes oh yeah well that's
right and the sort of a lower stakes one
is you get people to finish this
sentence hey the world isn't black and
white
it's multi-colored
see you this is why i didn't want to
play it with you because you you're the
one in ten simon that's why we're such
good pals
i'll tell you nine out of ten and maybe
it's eight out of ten
say gray right the world isn't black and
white it's shades of gray
and it's like you nod your head and
you're like no the world isn't black and
white it's color
and it's like we know it's color look
around i love that can i use that
please please this is why i love your
thinking
because nine out of 10 people go to one
direction
and you're the guy who says well what
about this
and everybody goes oh yeah i love that
seeing i in other words not only seeing
what that what is but seeing
alternatives and seeing what isn't there
and seeing new ways of thinking
it's sort of like that's where magic
happens i i've gone through this in past
relationships
and the word past is is operative here
which is when i'm in a relationship and
i start to focus on all the things that
are wrong
it's doomed because i literally see
nothing else we do this at work too
you have a colleague and you just see
all their mistakes and what they got
wrong
you can't get around it it becomes an
obsession
and all it takes is one person to say
well what's good
what did they do right and
instantaneously you have a list just as
long
yeah and it completely and profoundly
changes your view of this other person
and how you show up with them and how
you talk to them and how you interact
with them
so my wife is uh trained in art therapy
so i've learned a lot from
brooke right because um
it's a great trick and you and i did it
at that time with the embassy team but
if you get people to draw things as
opposed to
right things you you learn different
things that they kind of open up more
but there's a great thing if you go onto
youtube and you
search for uh gopro skiing the trees
for everyone i offended with hunting
metaphors we'll try to win them back
with skiing
but if you do if you show someone uh
like a
10 second clip of someone you know in
colorado skiing through the trees with a
gopro helmet
you know you say hey what's your
reaction to that image and everyone will
be like
holy [ __ ] trees like that's all you see
it's just
trees right that this guy is uh
flying through and you think um how do
they not die
well it turns out if you get a lesson
from a skate thing on how to do that
they only have one rule
don't you ever ever ever ever look at a
tree and then they say
just look for the white between the
trees and then you show the exact same
clip again
and all you see is the white yeah you
just see how much the really
most of the space in front of you isn't
trees it's white yeah and back to your
relationship point it's like
now it'd be pretty dumb to pretend there
are no trees right and i saw this like
weirdly just
from human relationships to the brexit
debate when i was there at the end of my
time in london
one side sort of seemed to be like there
are no trees everything's fine and the
other side is like it's just trees we're
all gonna get smashed up
yeah you know and you were like there
are trees now look for the spaces
that aren't trees yeah so the answer is
not this or that
it's not black and white it's a little
more
yeah it's color it's color they teach
pilots this by the way
you know the human brain cannot
comprehend the negative right
don't think of an elephant right right
yeah and so
when pilots are taught don't look at the
obstacle don't
hit the obstacle they like invariably
steer their planes into the obstacle
there was a
singapore airlines plane a bunch of
years ago that was told like don't hit
the tractor on the runway
and they full-on hit the tractor on the
runway because the pilots
are fixated on the tractor you know it's
like being fixated on the trees you're
gonna hit it
when you say follow the clear path or
follow you know then you fixate on the
clear path
yeah and it you know this is um high
school drivers education we have three
teenagers at home so this has been
you know top of mind at least when i was
taught how to drive you know obviously
staring at your phone and texting while
driving is like
really stupid and will get you killed
right right what is
counterintuitive is that if you do the
opposite
right and they have these weird trackers
yeah sweden which is like
car safety capital of the world so i
went to go see like where they test on
you see these videos of people driving
with the headsets on
and staring in their laps which is
dangerous and then they do the opposite
right and they just look at the road in
front of them
and that will get you killed too because
it's called tunnel vision
so it turns out we were all taught in
driver's ed the safe way to drive
is that little red x if you picture the
car safety
academy it should be moving every two
seconds ahead of you
behind you to the side in front of you
again way down the road upgrades
so guess what it looks like if you plot
safe driving
constellation a constellation of stars
it's called engaged driving
once you start to look at the world this
way it it
casts some strange shadows and on some
sort of sacred cows too so i mean i'm
just thinking about like
the most exhausting driving is like when
you're on a long road trip where you're
a little tired
and you still have to drive home and all
you do is
focus out the front window to stay awake
and get home safely but the reality is
it's
exhausting like road trips yeah are
exhausting when you start just
staring out the windshield focused on
driving but relaxed driving
is you as you said you check your side
mirrors you check your rear mirror you
look out the front you look to the side
you quickly change the radio you
you check and your eyes are all over the
place all the time
and it's not as exhausting what's
interesting so what i think is so
interesting about your work
is that you're telling us when you're
obsessed and fixated not only you're
exhausted you're not getting any help
you're not seeing any opportunity
and you might bag a deer but my god
you're missing out on so much more
that's it i mean it's why i think the
first three words of the book
uh are pretending is exhausting yeah
and we just do so much pretending that
we know
what the answer is and work our way back
from there pretending
we can factor out uncertainty just
pretending pretending pretending
and it's tempting because you think
you're doing the right thing yeah by
focus focus focus
but you know you're factoring out so
much you tell a story that is
i just love it and this is purely for me
who knows if it'll ever make it into the
podcast
this is just this is for one listener
can you please tell the story of cell
phones
and how we figured out how to make
dialing work on a cell phone
oh my god thank you for asking that it's
so good
okay so i learned about this amazing
woman when i was in sweden and her name
is lila
olgren she was the youngest
and the only female engineer
on this is the 1970s they have i think
it's finland sweden and norway i don't
know if denmark was part of it um if
this does make the podcast we'll learn
because i will have offended some danes
but i think it was just fins
swedes and norwegians trying to develop
cellular telephony so cell phones and
there was a race going on in the us to
do it too
anyway so they put all these engineers
in the room and they had figured out
almost all of it
right they had these cell towers along
the strip of highway in
sweden picture of volvo they actually
had carved wood handsets
it's really kind of quaint and awesomely
swedish so they figure out
almost all of it they have cell towers
they have the bulky
car phone and it all kind of works
except for one huge problem
which is as you're driving down the
highway
your phone your car phone establishes
contact with the first
base tower and you start to dial the
digits but then you keep going down the
road
and by the time you make connection with
the second tower along the road
you've lost connection with the first
one and so
the numbers get junk and it doesn't work
because what they're trying to do is get
the dial tones
they're trying to make it like a regular
pick up the phone hear the dial tone
dial the number
exactly so you establish connection with
the first hot tower you get your dial
tone you start dialing and then you lose
it before the next tower can pick it up
the clever people are like well okay you
could drive slower but that's dangerous
right or you could just have like many
more cell towers but that's sort of
in not feasible and really expensive so
everyone's stumped and so lila now i was
not in the meeting obviously but i like
to picture this that she sort of raises
her hand in the back
and says um what if we dialed the number
first
and then hit send and then i imagine it
sort of goes something like
what do you mean no dial tongue and
she's like
yeah we don't need a dial tone she says
there's a microchip
in this clunky cell phone it is more
than capable of just storing all the
numbers
and then sending them in one go so
her invention is called green button
dialing and it is on all
seven billion or whatever cell phones on
the planet
isn't that cool i mean it's there's an
entire generation
that recognizes that that's how
telephones work my kids have never heard
a dial tone
right you dial a phone number and then
you hit send rather than
get a dial tone to ensure that the line
is open we talk about is the line open
then you dial the phone number and it
goes through and i just love that this
young person with an entirely new
perspective who challenged
the pyramid thinking of the the senior
people in the room of how this works
and that is the standard of how we dial
a cell phone today i love that
and another one of the constellation
hero is this guy vince cerf who is
amazing um who co-invented the internet
right tcp ip protocol and i don't want
to get too dorky here but
he had a similar kind of insight right
that computer networking wasn't new
but the way it used to work is if i had
a computer and you had a computer
we would have a dedicated connection
right and we could only talk to each
other we were locked in but it was
really reliable
and so his innovation without getting
too much into the details was no no what
if we could talk to each other but there
wasn't any fixed connection we could
chop this up into a lot of different
pieces and in the end guarantee it got
assembled
and it was called an unreliable network
i mean to his his architecture so to
speak and it built the most reliable
network the world's ever seen
by making this sort of leap
of unreliability and leap of uncertainty
which is kind of cool well it's making
the leap from the fixed pyramid which is
certain
i know the direction it goes it goes up
or down
and it's and it's and it's saying we're
going to do a we're going to hook
computers up like a constellation
where each computer is a star and
that's it and that's it well and then he
describes and
then kindly came like you did kindly
came and just offered his time
to the embassy and when we did our
session with him um
he's getting all these questions from
awesome like activists and people are
rightly concerned back then and now with
wait a minute how's this internet thing
gone
and privacy concerns and surveillance
concerns all that kind of stuff was very
much in the news
um and he's sort of halfway through and
he's answering everyone's questions but
he says you know
you all tend to talk about the internet
like it's one big
thing and he's like it's not one thing
it's many things
and then he kind of goes he's like it's
not really a thing either
um and he's like the internet was a verb
yeah and i'm like oh that's cool he's
like we used to say
would you internetwork with me and he
said he was like asking someone to dance
and i thought that was so beautiful
because it's like
that leap of faith you have to make of
like i'm going to ask you to dance you
might say no
but if you say yes you know and there's
that
i l will you inter-network with me
and that's kind of that's the
constellation
let's change tax slightly you grew up in
massachusetts right outside of boston i
know something about you that i don't
think you know that i know
you were kind of a bit of a loner as a
kid right you had to take responsibility
for yourself at a certain age
yeah i lived alone slightly misleading
and
my lovely parents will maybe be
listening to this but my parents got
divorced when i was 11.
and my favorite place in the world was
in cape cod which was my father's
family's place so for understandable
reasons my mother
didn't want to go there for the summer
after they were divorced but i was like
well
the divorce that is your problem it is
not my problem
i am going to go down there um it's my
happy place
and so they wonderfully and sort of
miraculously said
okay so monday through friday i would
live alone at age 11 and my dad would
come down on weekends
that's insane you're 11. like i have an
i have an 11
year old niece i couldn't imagine
leaving her in a house by herself for
five days a week
there were relatives nearby do you know
what i mean so it wasn't like
i mean i was not raised by wolves and it
doesn't sort of sound that way but i did
learn a lot but you did you made
yourself breakfast every day
you took yeah i learned how to cook so
from the age of 11 5 out of 7 days
you raised yourself dude that's sort of
the story i tell myself
i think if i went back i mean it's true
um
it ended slightly the story you tell us
at the same time and it actually
happened
so i'm a great believer that the
solutions we find to the challenges we
have when we're kids
become our strength as adults so i was a
kid with
add and it wasn't a thing back then so
it wasn't
diagnosable i was just hyperactive and
couldn't focus and got yelled at
and didn't do my homework couldn't read
a book wasn't good at paying attention
but had this minor little problem i had
to still get through school
and so at a pretty young age i learned
to ask questions
and i learned to to listen to answers
and i learned to ask for help
a lot so i'd go talk to teachers after
class and ask them to explain it to me
i'd ask
my friends who were smarter than me and
i remember when i got to college
i had to take classes with good
professors because i couldn't skip class
because
i had to listen to the answer i couldn't
just like skip class and go read the
book and do fine because i couldn't get
through the book i didn't have the focus
to read a textbook
now as an adult that was all a survival
mechanism
the ability to ask for help and now as
an adult
the ability to ask questions and listen
for insight
i've made a career out of it it was all
a survival mechanism
that's where that skill came from of the
many kind things you've done
for me with me was when i got my
personal find your why with simon sinek
in the back of a heavily armored
ambassadorial car
and the weird thing about this moment
we're like driving from our residence to
the
uh embassy and you're like all right
let's just do it now
and i think great but we're not alone
right because we have security yeah
tony tony the driver and ben the
security guy in the front seat so we're
not alone but
you know you asked me for a specific
grown-up uh we're not gonna do it here
but a grown-up
uh thing i was proud of whether anyone
knew it or not and that kind of came
fairly easily which was this obama low
dollar fundraiser thing we talked about
earlier
and then the second thing you're like
specific childhood memory happy
childhood memory yeah
and it was like the most awkward silence
and i could just feel ben and tony in
the front being like
man and then i'm like and then i was
like i had a totally happy childhood i
have a wonderful mother and father and
siblings and friends and
but i really couldn't and then i started
saying lame ones and you wouldn't
in that great simon way you're like no
more specific more specific
more specific and i was like this is so
painful we're almost at the embassy it
put me out of my misery and then finally
i had one
that met your rigorous standard for
specificity and happiness
right which was teaching sailing um i am
probably
13 years old and i'm tiny like
prepubescent five foot nothing
and there's some little seven
eight-year-old kid
crying his eyes out in this tiny boat it
only fits one person
and the boom is going back and forth and
whacking him on the head and so the
older
teachers were like hey matthew you got
to go hop in that boat with him
and set him straight so i get off the
big boat
where the teachers all were hop into
this tiny boat because i fit and
wouldn't sink the thing
and just tell the little kid some basic
stuff so he could stop crying stop
getting hurt
and go off and sail and then they picked
me up and you're like great perfect
that's all i need
and i was like i don't get it and you
said big boat little boat
and then you said do me a favor like at
your desk at home buy a little toy boat
one big one little and put them there so
right you can't see it here but right on
my table
on the other side of the screen is a big
boat in a little boat because of your
ability
to sort of go between to go between and
i sort of need both i need sort of the
big boat with older people
wiser you know i most of my many of my
friends are a lot older than i am
because i just love learning from people
older and then being able to sort of hop
in the
little boat which is probably why i
loved going to sixth form colleges sort
of high school seniors
went to 200 schools 20 000 kids and i
now know where this comes from so i did
i mean i
i knew the insight but i didn't know the
origin story and the origin story is
this
this you as an 11 year old and your
ability to go between worlds
and it is true you know you're an
ambassador playing
at a very high level i mean you that's a
big job and you talk to other
ambassadors and world leaders
and then you spend more time than most
ambassadors
as you said visiting high schools to
talk to kids but you did it with your
own teams as well
you know most ambassadors live in their
ivory towers behind their behind all the
guarded walls
and you spent a lot of time with the
most junior people in the embassy
to share what you knew before you went
back into the big boat
and you're this constant big boat little
boat big boat little boat
is your happy place you know as you said
totally
and and i didn't know the origin story i
absolutely loved that
one of the things that makes you able to
go into a little boat is
is the humility because a lot of people
may attempt to get into the little boat
but because they bring all their weight
they sink the boat they suck the energy
out of the room they become blowhards
they become i know so much let me tell
you everything
and you're an experienced person who
gets into a little boat who shows up in
a room of kids and i've seen you do it
when you invited me to speak to the
embassy
unbeknownst to me you also invited me to
speak to kids that i didn't realize i
was doing
two things at the embassy that day but i
remember you were there with me and you
sat you didn't
like ladies and gentlemen simon and you
left you sat there
with the kids the whole time and then
you and i answered their questions
but you didn't lecture them
and most ambassadors lecture most people
from the big boat
lecture people on the little boat i love
it and i i seek it out
and that is me at my best and me at my
worst
is we debated you and i keeping this in
the book we ended up keeping it which
i'm glad but the story of where
i'm uh it's a wonderful couple invited
me to this big formal dinner and i was
supposed to
at the beginning of the meal stand up
and do what's called a tour de horizon
is it a diplomacy thing it's a diplomacy
a french term i'm not pronouncing well
well you got the tour de right thank you
um anyway so what is a tour de horizon
it's like a a survey of the waterfront
so like let me tell you
about um and in fact i had it's just one
thing i sort of had to do as ambassador
so you stand up and you provide the
the like the the pronouncements on u.s
foreign policy priorities and let's look
east of the relationship with china
let's look south to what's happening
in syria or south sudan it's an update
it is an update um and it is usually
expected to be given
in this tone of kind of often wrong
never in doubt yeah right which is sort
of the default diplomatic
tone um that i am capable of faking but
it's faking yeah when i do it anyway
um and uh but i got sort of good with
like i made it into a little memory game
north set and i'd be like you know look
east looks out look west
for the transatlantic trade deal look up
for the polar
you know climate and the melting polar
ice cap and so that sort of made it a
fun game internally for me because i
hated it
right and so my lovely wife brook's
there at the other she looks across the
table at me and it's like
you don't look good and i sort of shift
back and look like i don't feel good so
i like loosen my
tie and i was like oh dear i gotta get
out of here so i was like pardon me one
second it's sort of crowded so i like
scoot my way out and there's like
four like a little mini flight of stairs
to go to the bathroom and uh i don't
make it i just make it to the top of the
stairs
and i pass out in projectile vomit
everywhere
um or maybe projectile vomit and passed
out i don't remember
the order or maybe simultaneously but it
was humiliating this was like
a crowded restaurant we were like in the
private table in the back but like
everyone saw this yeah and
until i wake up like in the arms of
simon the security guy like catches me
as i pass out
and i wake up like smiling and i was
like totally relieved which is a weird
feeling when you've just humiliated
yourself and others
and i just sort of felt this like i'm
just not gonna i'm just not gonna do
this [ __ ] anymore
i'm not gonna pretend and so it's this
little mini epiphany
what was it about that experience that
gave you the confidence to give up
the lying hiding and faking you know i i
think it was in contract earlier that
morning i had been up in scotland
and i had done a bunch of these sessions
we talked about with the high schoolers
and they were dealing with scottish
independence they're dealing with
it wasn't yet brexit but just wrestling
with all these issues and it was so
energizing just watching and learning
from
this next generation and then the
contrast
with and this is my problem not our
wonderful hosts i mean they made me feel
welcome
you know what i mean and they may not
have even wanted the thing i thought
they wanted but
i just got myself in that strange place
so i'm just
allergic to pyramids and i don't
want to do it and i think the goal is
that the rest of us can give them up too
because constellations let's be honest
are so much prettier
so much prettier i'm so proud that
optimism press
is publishing your book i'm so proud
that we get to share
you know it's one of those things where
um for me you know i get to meet these
amazing people
and i get to learn from them and i count
you among them and it always bums me out
that other people aren't learning what
they know
and so for me one of the great joys is
getting to share
so much of the the things that you have
taught me with more people
that's what i love about the opportunity
to publish someone's book to publish
your book in particular
and it was so much fun backwards and
forwards with you as you were writing it
because it was the stuff that i cherish
in the stuff that i learned from you
that is now in that book and i don't
have to remember all the stories
so i guess this is my very long-winded
way i'm just saying thank you
thank you for sort of being willing to
put it out there
for giving up the pyramid and
championing the constellation because uh
it's it's a nicer way to live when you
see everybody else as a star
thank you
if you enjoyed this podcast and you'd
like to hear more please subscribe
wherever you like to listen to podcasts
until then take care of yourself take
care of each other